フライパンていうのは熱を通します
IHとかガスコンロで　‟ バッ ”　と炎が出てるところにこれをこう置いて
熱がこの金属に伝わってフライパン全体が熱くなる
そうやってフライパンは物を加熱することができます
で、今回この原理を使いまして
ちょっととある実験をしてみようと思いまして
フライパンをちょっとなるべく買ってみました
これは良いサイズだな
おお　オシャレオシャレ
で、今回気になったのはフライパンの熱の伝わり方はどこまで強いかと気になったので
例えばですよ
普通のフライパンでこうやって熱で熱してて
ここに物を置くと普通に焼けるのはわかる
ここにフライするものを置いた後に
さらに重ねて
熱がこの下のフライパンから伝わって
こっちのフライパンまで温かくなると
こっちのフライパンでも物がフライできる、ここで
で、ここで物をフライしたこのフライパンの上に
更にフライパンを重ねる
こっちでも更に物がフライできる
更ににここに物を...さらにここ
あっーーーーー！！！！！
とりあえず何が言いたいかというと
フライパンの上にフライパンを重ねて
そのフライパンが温かかったら更にそのフライパンの上に物を置いて更にそのフライパンにフライパンを置いてそのフライパンの上にも物を置いてそしてフライパンを更に置いてそこにまた物が焼けるというね
大量に一気に色んな物をフライできるという現象ができると僕は考えたわけです
まじで意味わかんないなぁ
とりあえず！フライパンの熱のその伝わる感じを調べてみようと思いました
では早速やってみましょう
普通にフライパンをやっても温かくなるだけなのはわかっているんで
ではまずは加熱していきましょう
はい、というわけで点火しました
ここに今からフライパンを乗せていく
行ってらっしゃい
普通に一個だったらここだけが
熱くない？もう
あっーーー！！！
もうダメだもうダメだ
多分普通に水を入れてもこれをかけて蒸発しますよ
ほら、わかりますか？
水を入れたらもうあんなことになっちゃいます
この熱いフライパンに更にフライパンを重ねていきましょう
2個目
え？
3個目
4個目
5個目
6 7 8 9 10 10!!
あ、１１だわ
11 12
これがラストだ
はいというわけでこんな感じになりました
今回気になるのは本当にこれが熱としてこうフライパンで上に伝わるかどうかでございます
フライパン自身の熱の伝わり方
そしてフライパン自身から発する：；＠\\/:[\]」－／／：，＜＋‘＊｛｝｛
熱自身
熱伝導とフライパン自身から発せられる熱で果たしてフライパンの熱はどこまで上に伝わるかが今回の見どころでございます
もうちょっと熱してみましょう
これまじでわかんねぇなぁ
本当多分ね微妙なとこだと思います
あのフライパン２枚目３枚目熱いのは間違いないんだけども
上までくると熱いかどうかわからない
はいというわけで充分に時間を置きました
果たしてフライパンはどこまで熱が伝わるのか
実際に僕の素手で試したいと思います
はい、素手で試したいと思います
あーーーやだーーー！！！
もー、やだやだやだやだやだ
やります
こん　にち　は
みきぽんです　はいこんにちはみきぽんです
はい、というわけでねみきぽんチャンネルやっていこうと思いますよ
あぁっ、びっくりした
まずは一番上12枚目でございます
っしゃあ
てやーーーーっ！！
あっ！！！
熱くない
まままあまあまあね
さすがに熱を伝えるフライパンでも１２枚も熱を伝わることはないということがわかりました
お疲れさまっす！
１１枚目です
はーっ！！
あっ！！！
つくない
１０枚目いきます
てーっ！！
あぁ・・・。
熱くない
これリアクションしずらいな
９枚目
ちょっと嫌な予感がした
そろそろやばいかも
８枚目いきます
はぁーっ！！
あぁっ熱っ！！！
はぁあ、はっ、はっ
はっ、はっ、ああ、ああ
次だ
多分次・・・熱いちょっと熱い
７枚目です　そろそろやばい気がしてきました
はぁあーーーっ！！！！！
はっ、熱い
絶対熱いよ
はぁっ！！
あっ！！
ちなみに、5枚目はどうなんだろう
ふぅっ！？
５枚目は本当にやばい
５枚目はやばい
はっ、待って待って待って待ってちょっと
ほんとにほんとにほんとに熱い　ダメ、ダメ　ほんとに